let's talk about black seed it's
quite interesting it's been around
for a very long time in many cultures they
actually found these black seeds present
in the ancient egyptian tomb of the
pharaoh Tutankhamun which is king tut
so the properties of this oil in black seed
is quite extensive so let's go to the list
asthma hypertension diabetes pain inflammation
antimicrobial anti-fungal antiviral antibacterial
number seven anti-cancer the anti-phytonutrient
called thymoquinone it actually causes the
cancer to commit suicide without creating any
problem on normal cells it's called apoptosis
there's a study which i'll list below apparently
black seed is a significant inhibitor of solid
tumors in mice now the other mechanism of how
it deals with cancer which is quite interesting
it says somatostatin analog now let me explain
what that means an analog is something that
mimics something and somatostatin is a hormone
that lowers or inhibits growth hormone insulin
and glucagon but the black seed oil was the only
natural somatostatin analog that i could find
out of a database of thousands and thousands of
natural remedies so this right here will create
an anti-cancer effect because it blocks certain
pathways that allow the cancer to get its material
its raw material to grow and then we get to number
eight anti-convulsant so if someone has a seizure
this could help them all right number
nine neural protection so if there's
um a lot of free radical damage or oxidation going
on the brain black seed can help counter that so
it's a powerful anti-oxidant all right number
10 it can protect against kidney disease like a
kidney problem from having diabetes or a kidney
problem that is developed from a person taking
tylenol antibiotics certain steroids being exposed
to lead mercury cadmium aluminum and even morphine
so black seed oil is very very protective on
the kidney if someone is in a situation where
they have to take certain medications that
have a lot of side effects it's also diuretic
it can also help to inhibit dermatitis which is a
skin problem it can help support the immune system
by increasing phagocytosis which are the cells
that gobble up and clean up infection and it's
anti-gas so in summary black seed pretty much
handles about every single problem that you may
experience thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today